I think that it's um, give me some
advice. I don't know enough about it.
I'm an idiot.
I just on anything on anything money
related cause you have an icon jeep so I
know you have more money.
I just work a lot.
We'll such grandfather leaves. That's
true. That's the shit. My grandfather,
I'm not a big, I'm not a big investor.
I'm not very smart. I got you.
I have people handling that kind of stuff,
which you don't work a lot but I don't
pay attention to anything guilty now.
Yeah.
I do too many things myself to the place
where I know exactly what I have to pay
attention to them.
What I don't want,
I don't have to pay attention
to is just gone shot.
Robert Paul lay my accountant
has made it pretty easy for me.
He is literally a graph.
This is a dollar you make.
This is what goes into savings.
This is what goes into advancement.
This is what you and Shay
weren't invested in real estate.
This is for retirement. So now everything
that comes in and I already know.
So it's like when they call us until like,
hey you guys,
you guys got a $500,000 a day.
I just know that I'm not going home
with two 50 because asset management
conditions, my wife and my accounting
already chop that shit up. So
I got enough money to buy a Camaro.
Yeah,
I don't like to think about that.
I had just to think about now cause
you know I'm black and you know shit,
I ain't been too good if you like,
but it got my live view poor and black.
If you pour America's fucked up.
Yeah. If you pour in black Americans,
fuck that with a deal during ass.
So you know, my whole shit is,
let me take care of my money because
my grandpa and my grandmother,
her family owned land,
they started as sharecroppers,
but because they are land she could,
she could become educated because
they could sail the stuff.
They grew to stores and produce markets
and stuff. So she named were Methodist.
So she got to go to school. My
grandfather, some other old no land.
So my grandfather had to work in a
bread factory in cotton meals and shit.
So I knew the difference
between ownership and you know,
the advantages of having something in it.
So it's something I can have obsessed
on because I don't want my children to
endure poverty. And I, and I grew
up working class, you know, my wife,
she jokes, but she said
to the lot, you know,
she was from housing projects in Savannah
and her grandmother and her mother
worked. They were out of there. But you
know, she says to me, me all the time,
you were spoiled. You know, you're
a little rich kids. I'm like,
what are you talking about? She's
like, you had a fucking RV. I'm like,
I lived in an a frame house. She's
like, I don't care. Your Grandpa,
your grandparents couldn't afford a RV.
You guys went on vacation.
You were spoiled. Right? So I
understand money means a lot,
and it doesn't mean everything to me,
but it helps to afford me to be able
to take care of her. My children,
I completely understand it,
but I don't really give a shit.
Knock on a daily basis. I'm
more like you, I just you,
but you think about businesses,
you think about starting
businesses and forming businesses.
How do you have the time to do that and
write and perform and all the other shit
that you do? Because it enabled the
business is enabled me to enjoy writing.
They're performing. When I had to
wrap, when it was no choice, um, it,
it wasn't as fun anymore because the
pressure was, am I going to chart,
can I make this much? Will
the record versus, you know,
if I have a couple of shaves in
revenue coming in, you know, it,
it makes it a little more relaxed and
my art is freer that way, you know?
Ooh, I like that answer. That's
a great answer. That makes sense.
That makes a lot of sense actually.
Yeah.
To free yourself up creatively so that
all you have to think about when you're
doing that, you're just doing
what you want to do. Yeah.
That's it. Yeah. That's it.
Yeah, man, that's ideal. That's wise.
That's the goal. Yeah. If I'm a, you know,
a lot of people talk a lot of shit about
billionaires they like and they want to
be,
and then Daryl,
there are tons of billionaires from the
nerdy sexy or Bill Gates to the wild,
dope, eccentric, sexy of Eli Musk to
the ogs of Warren Buffett and shit.
I like Ted Turner, Ted Turner as
well. Ted was the guy who got nine,
got snookered out of six, ended up
with one or two and it's like, man,
I'm living in my fucking life
growing bice and eating good meat.
Where's the fucking cowboy hat with
my funky mustache? And like he's,
he was such a good owner of teams and
our city, when he owned the teams,
he was a great man with TBS and he did a
lot of good. He's, if you know, if I, if,
if, if a billion is the new
style, I want to be a billionaire,
but of having a lot of money's a standard,
I'd like to be the quirky,
eccentric guy. Like Ted, he
always seemed free to me. Yeah.
Especially once you got rid of Jane
Fonda that shouts out to listen.
When he married Jane Fonda the south,
where we literally thought it was, oh man,
it was like the city of Atlanta had
went back to gone with the wind.
It was just amazing. Again, it was,
people were strutting around that,
you know Jane Fonda's virtual, our first
lady, well you know, if he will start to,
but I choose a nice lady to the city.
David Justice and highly
Barry were interesting too.
Not an interest in is to some bastard.
He was hands one motherfucking the world.
Was it? What's the, um, what's the
yachting if anyone, I don't know,
the Yada he who's,
he got into Yachty and out of nowhere
because cup the America's cup was it,
was that right?
Yeah.
Ted Turner lived a life that
Ralph Lauren puts on tee shirts.
Yeah. He looks like a, like a
billionaire and a movie too.
He does great Gatsby tie.
He does.
He does some guy who's a wise billionaire.
It brings you into this study and you
have a scotch with him on ice. Exactly.
Explain Shit to you. And you're like, what
in the fuck? Shouts out to tay it man.
I know you don't get your love like
a lot of the other guys. The cut,
he does the fucking Montana ground bison.
He's out there chilling man.
We bound it. The population of Bison
so he could cook them and eat them.
It's like get the fuck out of here.
That's bad ass man. But those overalls,
respect. That's how my fucking grandfather
dressed with the same mustache.
That's what I want to be like when I
think about making 21 million escaping the
game and shit. This is me like maybe
overalls in a Braves cap, but this is it.
Now let me ask you this,
how far away from him are dudes
with machine guns at all times,
but he's in fucking Montana but so what?
I can drive to Montana stick.
He'll take turn tenant who wants to
come in? No one wants to kill Turner.
She get some money, Bro. No one wants to
kill. I would imagine she has two snipers.
He probably has. He probably has
two snipers say east and west,
and he has one guy within a few
feet of him, but very relaxed.
I don't think teds walking
around like Kadafi.